[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه معي العيال اختيار استهلوها بابره
العناوين
قررت السلطات القطريه بالتعاون مع الفيفا
بتكثيف
امنيه مشدده داخل ملعب الثمامه وخارجه
قبيله لقاء المنتخبين الامريكي والايراني
نظرا
[موسيقى]
الشتاء يجبر الناتو على التدخل في
اوكرانيا قطع غيار ومولدات لتعويض نقص
الطاقه
طهران تستغل اتفاقا امنيا بين اربيل
واحزاب ايران الكرديه يمنعها من الرد على
صواريخ الحرس الثوري
تستخدم العملات المشفره لتمويل لبرنامجها
الصاروخي عبر قرصنه ملايين الدولارات
الرقميه
[موسيقى]
بعد ساعه من الان تنطلق مباراه منتخب
الولايات المتحده مع المنتخب الايراني
معركه رياضيه تنقلها السياسه وتثقلها
السياسه ولا مهرب من ذلك قبل المباراه نشر
الاتحاد الامريكي لكره القدم صوره العلم
الايرانيه الاساسيه قبل الثوره الخميليه
اي العلم دون شعار النظام الاتحاد
الامريكي قال لشبكه سي ان ان تغيير العلم
الرسمي سيكون لمده 24 ساعه فقط لاظهار
الدعم للنساء في ايران عدد من مشجعي
المنتخب الايراني حاول دخول المدرجات
حاملين اعلام بلادهم القديمه قبل عهد
خميني في رساله الاحتجاجيه وداعمه
للمتظاهرين لكن الامن رفض دخولها
باعتبارها لافتات سياسيه حسب ما نقلت
رويترز وسائل اعلام رسميه ايرانيه طلبت
بطرد الولايات المتحده من البطوله وايقاف
منتخبها 10 مباريات بسبب نشر صوره مشوهه
للعلم بحسب وصفها طبعا مشاهدينا اي مباراه
بين فريقاي البلدين دائما ما حملت جانبا
سياسييا الزميل ليث البزاري امام استاذ
ثمامه ينقل لنا التفاصيل في المتابعه
تنطلق من خلفي بعد اقل من ساعه من الان في
ستاد الثمامه بالعاصمه القطريه الدوحه
مباراه حاميه الوطيس بين منتخبين ايران
وامريكا في الجوله الثالثه الختاميه
لمجموعات بطوله كاس العالم لكره القدم قطر
2022 نظرا للوضع الجيو سياسي بين البلدين
قرارات السلطات القطريه بالتعاون مع
الفيفا بتكثيف اعداد القوات الامن
والحمايه المدنيه في محيط وداخل هذا
الملعب يبدو ان عدد المشجعين الايرانيين
اكثر بكثير من المشجعين الامريكان نظرا
لقرب دوله قطر من ايران ووجود عدد لا باس
به من الايرانيين في المنطقه ما سهل عليهم
بالقدوم الى هنا اما المشجعين الامريكيون
فقد حضر الكثير منهم من الولايات المتحده
لتشييع فرقها هنا في بطوله العالم في قطر
وكذلك السياحه في الدول العربيه المجاوره
من امام استاذ الثمامه
دوله قطر
[موسيقى]
معنى مشاهدينا من الدوحه
العربيه ليس كيف هي صوره
قبيله انطلاق مباراه يعني الاداره والنظام
من هناك
نعم ليال يعني كما تشاهدين الصوره هي توضح
ما يحدث هناك امريكيون يحتفلون
ويشجعون الفريق المنتخب الامريكي وهناك
ايرانيون كذلك اتوا من طهران ومن مناطق
اخرى من ايران يقومون بالاحتفالات واذا
اخذنا الكاميرا وذهبنا سويا مع المشاهدين
سوف نرصد كيف يتم دخول همم طريقين يدا بيد
احيانا حضور المباراه التي انطلقت التي
ستنطلق عفوا بعد اقل من
56 دقيقه من الان يعني المباراه التي تجمع
ايران والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ستقام في هذا ستاد
وكذلك سيتم يعني دخول ال- ال- ال- همم
شاهدنا دخول الكثير من الحافلات الامريكيه
التي وصلت الى مواقف السيارات هنا الكثير
منهم اتىوا من مناطق مختلفه من
من من التكساس من كلورادو من مناطق مختلفه
وكثير من الايرانيون يعني قاموا بالحديث
هذه طبعا
الذي حدث طبعا هنا في هذه همم في هذا
الملعب او قبل دخول المباراه كان هناك
حديث شيق استمعت الى سيده امريكيه تتحدث
مع سيده ايرانيه قالت لها همم الذي يحدث
سياسيا لا ينعكس ابدا الذي يحدث
في الدوحه او في مونديال قطر 2022 والكثير
منهم يحاول طبعا ان يتقرب من الاخر ويتعرف
على ثقافه الاخر وكان هناك قبل قليل
احتفال موسيقي ايراني وفارسي اقيم في هذه
الساحه كما نشاهد نشاهد هناك في الخلف
هناك احتفالات مستمره وهناك العديد من
الاشخاص الذين ياتون
ويحتفلونزا وهناك طبعا هتافات علي كريم
علي كريم وهو لاعب المنتخب الايراني ومن
ثم انطلقوا وحاولوا يتعرفوا على بعضها من
بعض اذا اخذنا الكاميرا ولكن
ولكن يعني التي الذي يجمعهم هو الكره هذه
الرساله التي وصلت او التي تريد قطر من
هذا المونديال ان توصلها ان
الحياه الرياضيه والثقافه الرياضه هي التي
تجمع بين الفرق ما بعرف اذا الى ماذا الى
اين يمكن ان نصل في النقطه الاخيره قبل
دخول
همم ولكن ليس هل يمكن ان نتحدث الى بعض
المشجعين الامريكيين بما انهم قطعوا مسافه
طويله للوصول الى الدوحه اذا كان يعني اي
من المشجعين حول
ساحاول ان اصل الى احد المشجعين
الامريكيين قد يكونوا في الجهه الاخرى
هناك امريكيون نعم نعم
فودا
هم وصلوا من تكساس الخميس الماضي يوم
الجمعه الماضي
[موسيقى]
اوكي نعم هما وصلوا من تكساس عبر لندن
وسوف وكانت الرحله سهله للوصول الى الى
قطر هاو ار يو سبارتينج ده يو اس
واي مبابي
فرنسيه وهم طبعا يحاول دائما دعوه نلاحظ
ذلك على القميص هناك الديك الفرنسي وهنا
يو اس ايه القميص الذي يرتدي
المنتخب الامريكي او او القميص الرسمي
المنتخب الامريكي ونشاهد اللاعبين المنتخب
الامريكي على على العالم الذي يحملون
العالم الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هذه
الاجواء هنا وسوف نشاهد يعني شاهدنا ليال
الكثير من قوات الامن من قوات الخاصه التي
تقوم بحراسه همم
الملاعبنا ان الكثير منهم يا هناك سيدات
هذه الاملاحظها من قبل هناك سيدات يقومنا
بالحراسه بشكل دوريات من سته او سبعه
اشخاص يقوموا بتجوال حوالي همم
الخارجيه وكما شاهدنا ايضا هناك هتافات
وشاهدنا ايضا ملفاتني ان بعض الفتيات
يحملنا سوره سوبر معتقلين في السجون
الايرانيه ويطالبون بالعداله وهؤلاء
الاشخاص عبر طبعا هذه اليافطات صورنا بعد
منها بعضا منها قبل قليل قبل ساعه من الان
واا طبعا شاهدنا كذلك صوره محسن امين همم
وكذلك يعني اشخاص اخرون والكثير منهم
اهتار الحريه اذا جاء الينا والبس بروسلي
ههه
يعني هذه الاجواء تعرفوا احنا عاده
الامريكان لما يكونوا في مباراه هو يعني
هو اكثر من الرياضه هي الشوق او العرض
الذي يقام فالكثير منهم شاهدنا ملابس
غريبه حضرت الى هنا يرتدي طبعا الامريكان
الامريكان وكذلك يحملون لافتات غريبه
والبعض منهم تخيل ليال اتوا على دراجات
دراجات الهوائيه من وسط الدوحه الى هنا
لمشاهده المباراه واذا يعني تجولنا في
مناطق اخرى سوف نحاول دعيني احاول احاول
ولو مره محاوره الدخول بالكاميرا مع انه
ممنوع بس خلينا نجرب سوريا
نعم نعم هذه الاجواء بيكون يعني حلوه انه
نفوت نعم هذه الاجواء التي نشاهدها اليوم
هي اجواء المهرجان وهذه ال- ال- ال-
الحراسه التي
تقوم تفتيش كل شخص ياتي الى هنا ومن ثم
يدخلون هذا الملعب نحن الان في ساحه
الملعب دخلنا شفت زبطت معنا يا زلمه معنا
يلا اذا دخلنا في المناطق همم ههه
نعم هنا نشاهد اجواء اخرى هنا شاشه عرض
تقوم بعرض المباراه الذين يقفون هنا وهناك
اشخاص من جنسيات مختلفه ياتون الى هذا
المكان هناك من طبعا الكثير من الجوالات
يقومون بتصوير الساحه وتصوير
مبنى الملعب الذي نشاهد على خلف الصوره
على ما يبدو محاولتك
تم فشاله يا ليث
هنا طبعا نشاهد ما يتصورون
يتصورون صور تذكاريه هنا في الملعب وهناك
طبعا مشجعون ايرانيون
والكثير منهم يحمل يا قطط باسماء اطفال
كره القدم في ايران كريمي وغيرهم واذا
اذن الى هنا على ما يبدو انتهت
رحله الزميل ليث او عاد الينا عاد الينا
وقت
ليس سنكمل معك اذا كنت قادر على الدخول
حنحاول الدخول الى ساحه الملعب
نعم وهناك طبعا البوابه رقم 11 التي لا
اعلم لا اعلم اين تؤدي هذه البوابه ولكن
يحصل على الاقل ما يحدث
في حال استطعت الدخول
انقل لنا اجواء المباراه من الداخل
واستمتع بها ليث شكرا لك مفضله العربيه
ليس بازاري من الدوحه على هذه الصوره
اهلا بكم من جديد نددت المانيا ودول غربيه
بالقصف الروسي لمشاه الطاقه الاوكرانيه
بهدف تدميرها حيث وصفت مدينه تلك ضربات
الروسيه بجريمه حرب يجب ان تتم محاسبه
موسكو عليها بدورها شددت وكاله الطاقه
الدوليه على ان روسيا خسرت اوروبا كاكبر
عميل لها في مجال الطاقه بعد حربها
الاخيره وتركيز قصفها على البنيه التحتيه
في اوكرانيا ولان الشتاء سيكون قاسيا بدون
الطاقه تتركز الجهود الغربيه الان على
دعمك بمزودات ومشغلات الطاقه حيث اعلن
الناتو تسليم اوكرانيا قطع غيار ومولدات
طاقه لتعويد البنيه التحتيه المدمره ومن
المرشحه ان تقدم واشنطن منفرده ايضا دعما
كبيرا لك في مجال الطاقه
اذا حرق دولي مكثف سيما من حلفاء اكياز
لمساعدتها في تدارك النقص والازمه في مجال
الطاقه سواء عبر دعمها بالغاز والكهرباء
او مساعدتها في النهوض مجددا عبر اصلاح
منشاتها التي دمرها القصف الروسي بدورها
تبذل اوكرانيا جهودا حثيثه لاستعاده
التيار الكهربائي بشكل كامل بعد نحو اسبوع
من موجب ضربات صاروخيه روسيه الحقت اضرار
جسيما بمنشات للطاقه في انحاء البلاد ومع
استمرار ضربات روسيه على البنا التحتيه في
اوكرانيا اعلنت اكياس ان القصر الروسي
استهدف البنيه تحتيه في مقاطعه نيترو
جنوبيه البلاد فمن الطاقه الى مصادر مياه
الشرب بدات توسع اهدافها داخل اوكرانيا
اذا ان الضربات استهدفت ايضا مضخات المياه
في ميكولاج التي تتم عبر او تمر عبر خرسون
جنوبا وعلى ذكر خيرسون اعلن الحاكم
الاقليمي للمدينه انهم استطاعوا حتى الان
تامين فقط
17% من الكهرباء للمشتركين لمشاهدين على
ان اعاده التيار باقي المناطق سيتم قريبا
بشرط عدم استهداف المزيد من البنيه
التحتيه من قبل روسيا قبل ذلك انذر الرئيس
الاوكراني نيفلودينيوزيلنسكي مواطنيه
باسبوع اخر من الظلام والبرد متوقعه عن
مزيد من الضربات الروسيه المتركزه على
منشات الطاقه في البلاد وقال ذكي ان رد
موسكو على فشلها الكبير على ارض المعركه
سيكون بالحاق المزيد من الدمار بالبنيه
التحتيه لاوكرانيا مشددا على ان موسكو
ستقصف بلاده حتى نفاذ صواريخها من جهته
شدد وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني
ديميتروكوليبا على ان بلاده بحاجه ملحها
الى محولات كهربائيه فضلا عن دفاعات جويه
محسنه لصد الضربات الجويه الروسيه على
البنيه التحتيه للطاقه
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا حذيفه عادل مراسل العربيه
حذيفه كيف هي الصوره هناك يعني مع موجه
الثلوج التي عمت البلاد
يعني صوره صوره تتحدث عن نفسها يعني الوضع
حار جدا في جميع انحاء اوكرانيه في جميع
التي تم نقاشها هو مواصله المساعدات
للدوله الاوكرانيه سواء كان على الصعيد
العسكري او لانظمه الطاقه في اوكرانيا
التي تواجه وضع حرج جدا طبعا كان من
المفترض ان يشارك في الاجتماع الرئيسي
لمترو كوليبا وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني الا
ان المتجر طبعا تقدم بطلب رفضت همم يشارك
بصفه رسميه في الاجتماع الرئيسي وطبعا
بناء على هذا الطلب لم يشارك او تم حظر
مشاركه وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني دي متروك
الامير همم قام همم باجراء همم قام به
تجهيز بعض الاجتماعات
ل- اا وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني دي
متروكوليبا على هامس هذا همم
الاثنين الرئيسي همم انعقد همم عقد عده
اجتماعات مع وزراء خارجيه بعض الدول وكانت
نتيجه ذلك مزيد من المساعده طبعا شدد هذه
متر كوليبا على ان ا ا ا وتيره وصول
المساعدات الى اوكرانيا هو الاهم الان اذا
المساعدات اتصل بوتيره بطيئه وذلك يعني
يجعل همم المشكله تحل في زمن اطول ايضا
طبعا المعدات الاساسيه لاصلاح نظام
التشغليه الاهم بالنسبه للجانب الاوكراني
بالاضافه الى المعدات نعم موضوع الطاقه
واصلاح نظام الطاقه واعاده الكهرباء خصوصا
ان نتحدث عن الملايين اليوم يعني بيظل هذا
الطقس البارد كيف ستستطيع اكياس الصمود
كيف تستطيع لا يعني لم اسمع كيف ستستطيع
اكياس الصمود اليوم وتامين مستلزمات
الطاقه
نعم اولا هنالك مساعدات بالفعل قد وصلت
الى الجانب الاوكراني ابتدات اول الدول
كانت فرنسا التي ارسلت معدات الصيانه
ومعدات هامه لاستعاده التيار ولكنها لا
تكفي طبعا بعد ذلك طبعا اعلنت الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه عن 53 مليون دولار خاصه
معدات الطاقه والاستعاده النظام الطاقه في
الدوله الاوكرانيه ايضا طبعا تم حذف جميع
دول حلف الناتو بمواصله الدعم واستمرار
الدعم بمزيد من الدعم لنظام الطاقه ايضا
لابد ان نتحدث عن همم الدفاع الجوي الذي
تطالب به اوكرانيا دائما يبدوا ان هنالك
الان حديث اليوم في هذا الاجتماع العام
كان هنالك حديث عن انه يجب ان تكون هنالك
افضليه ولو جزئيه لاوكرانيا في الجول هذا
الامر الذي
تفتقده تماما كيف في هذه المعركه يبدو انه
هنالك الان نقاش يدور حتى الان لم يتخذ
القرار ولكن هنالك نقاش حول تزويد
اوكرانيا قد يكون بطائرات اف 6 او بطائرات
الميج 29 او بنظام باتريوت الامريكي همم
للدفاع الجوي او انظمه انظمه الدفاع الجوي
هي اقل ذلك واقل يعني فعاليه من ذلك ولكن
الان ااه تم الاتفاق على انه لابد من ان
يكون هنالك حتى ولو في المناطق الخاصه
بالطاقه ان يكون هنالك نظام دفاع جوي شكرا
لك حذيفه عادل على هذه الرساله من اكياس
وسط تساقط الثلوج شكرا لك حذيفه
كل الدعم الغربي بالاسلحه اليوم همم موسكو
تستعمل سلاح البرد هل تعول روسيا على
هزيمه اوكرانيا الثلوج
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]
تقريبا شهرين تقريبا تقريبا
من الممكن سوف تكون انقطاعات كهرباء على
همم مده طويله حتى مده الاولى
انتم تعلمون ان موسكو عولت بكثير من
حروبها بالحرب العالميه الثانيه بالقرن ال
19 على موضوع الطقس والبرد حتى ان
النازيين كانوا يسمونه جنرال جليد اليوم
يعني لماذا لم تاخذ اكياس بالحسبان هذه
النقطه قبل دخول الموسم السادس
[موسيقى]
في في هذا المجال همم لكن نحن نشهد بان
روسيا
فقط
بجنيه هي كمان
وتسريبه الشعر همم في من محطه همم من محطه
نوويه سوف تكون امامنا في المستقبل
لتحديات مختلفه من ليس فقط تجميل همم ولكن
الناس شديد صحيح اوكرانيا لن تكون لن تكون
مستعد في في في في في في هذا خارب في حرب
بين روسيا سوف تستخدمه
حضرتك
شخصيا كان هذا الشيطان هو صوتك
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
ما يزالوا اهالي بلده كويس انشق بكردستان
العراق متخوفون من احتمال تجدد القصف
الصاروخي والمدفعيه الايراني على المنطقه
التي تتخذ منها احزاب كرديه ايرانيه
معارضه مقرا لها فيما ردد كريم فرخبور احد
قاده الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستان الايراني
بقصف الحرس الثوري للمواقعه المشدده على
ان الاحزاب والفصائل الكرديه لم تنفذ اي
هجوم من هذه المقرات على ايران فلذلك
القصف غير مبرر وفق القياد الكردي والذي
اضاف ان النظام الايراني بقصه لاقليم
كردستان يحاول تشتيت الانتباه عن ما يجري
من احتجاجات داخل ايران
[موسيقى]
الى جانب التوجه الى القومي وبعضها ليسري
تشجع هذه الفصائل والاحزاب الكرديه
الايرانيه القيم النسويه في صفوفها وغالبا
ما تقدم نفسها على انها احزاب اجتماعيه
ديمقراطيه على راس هذه الاحزاب ياتي الحزب
الديمقراطي لكردستاني فرع ايران وهو اقدم
حزب كردي ايراني ويؤكد انه يكافح من اجل
تجسيد حقوق الاكراد القوميه في اطار ايران
فيدراليه واديمقراطيه اما عن واقع انتشار
قواعده الشعبيه في الداخل الايراني فت فاز
على كردستان ايران حيث مدن مهابات وسقز
وماريوان وكاميران وسرداشت وهناك احزاب
كومالا او حزب كومالا الكردستاني ذات توجه
يسري قومي لطالما نادى بانشاء دوله
كردستان ايران ويمتلك معسكرات ومقار
عسكريه في اقليم كردستان على بعد 100 كيلو
متر من الحدود مع اراد وتتركز قاعدته
الشعبيه في الداخل الايراني بالمناطق
الكرديه لا سيما في مهاباد وسقاز وسرداش
اوريميا واطرافها ومن بين الفصائل الاخرى
التي استهدفت خلال الاشهر الاخيره بالقصف
الايراني حزب الحريه الكردستانيه الذي يضم
مقاتلين شاركوا في معارك ضد داعش في
كردستان العراق وينتشر بقوه في مناطق الام
وسنه ومهباد ومروان وكارمنشاه وسقاظ
وارميا
في الداخل الايراني وهناك ايضا الحزب
الديمقراطيه لكردستاني في كردستاني ايران
بزعامه خالد عزيزي ويعتبر الحزب منشقا عن
الحزب الاساسيه وهو الديمقراطي لكردستاني
ايران وهو الاخر ايضا يمتلك قاعده شعبيه
كبيره في الداخل لاسيا في ماريوان ومهباد
وسرداش وسقز وكاميران وارميه
[موسيقى]
الجامعات والاحزاب الكرديه الايرانيه
المعارضه وجود قديم في اقليم كردستان
العراق وذلك منذ ثمانيات القرن الماضي
خلال الحرب العراقيه الايرانيه وكانت
بمباركه صدام حسين لكن مقار هذه الاحزاب
وقياداتها لطالما كانت بمرمى الاهداف
الايرانيه
وقصفها منذ ذلك الوقت
خليها عن نشاطها المسلحه وانشطتها المسلحه
وتركيزها فقط على العمل السياسي بالرغم من
انها تمتلك اسلحه ولديها مقاتلين ومعسكرات
في اقليم كردستان العراق الا ان الاحزاب
الكرديه الايرانيه لا تستطيع الرد على
القصف الايراني والسبب هنا مانع وحاجز من
داخل الاقليم
نفسهم بين هذه الاحزاب الكرديه الايرانيه
والحزب الحاكم في اقليم كردستان بزعامه
مسعود برزاني يمص على السماح بوجود هذه
الاحزاب مقابل عدم انخراطها في عمل عسكري
ضد جيران الاقليم لتفادي زعزعت علاقه
الاقليم مع ايران وغيرها
وتجمع روابط تاريخيه بين اقليم كردستان
العراق وكردستان ايران في شمال غربي
البلاد يتحدث سكان المنطقه الكرديه نفسها
وكثر من بينهم لديهم اهل واقربا من طرفي
الحدود بين البلدان
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من اربيل الدكتور
استاذ الفلسفه السياسيه في جامعه كوريا
استاذ يعني من المعلوم بانه بالقوانه
الاخيره ايران تضغط على السلطات الرسميه
في كردستان
لاما وضع المقاتلين بمعسكرات او ايقاف عدد
منهم والحد من انشطهم السياسيه وغيرها هل
ممكن ان تخضع السلطات هناك للضغط
الايرانيه
مساء الخير
اسمحي لي بدايه نقوم بتصحيح بعض العناوين
في المنشات
ويبدو انها مستقاء من معلومات قديمه
اولا لم يعد هناك حزبان ديمقراطيات برئاسه
السيد خالد عزيزي ومصطفى هجري الان
الحزبان توحد قبل ااه شهرين من الان
تقريبا
برئاسه السيد مصطفى الهجري ونائبه الاستاذ
خالد عزيزي ايضا حزب كومه لجناحان ال
المنشقان توحدات قبل اربعه ايام بحيث بات
هناك حزب ديمقراطي الكردستاني
كردستان واحد بقياده واحده هذا بالنسبه
لتصحيح المعلومات التي وردت في مقدمه همم
الضغوطات همم لم تكفن لم يكف النظام
الايراني عن ممارسه بعض
عقدين من الزمن على حكومه الاقليم وعلى
الدوام كانت تطالب بتسليم المعارضين وقد
ذكرتم في التقرير ان الاحزاب الكردستانيه
الايرانيه التزمت منذ وقت منذ تسعينات من
بدايه تاسيس الحكومه المحليه الكرديه بوقف
النشاطات العسكريه انطلاقا من اراضي
الاقليم لاسباب امنيه وجيوس سياسيه الان
النظام الايراني يمارس مزيد من الانا
الاستاذ في جامعه كويت كما تعلمون والكويا
هي نفسها كويسنجه
وسبق وان همم تعرضنا في في اكثر من مره
الى قصف ايراني مباشر بالصواريخ وبي- همم
الطائرات وهذه الاماكن المعروضه انا زرتها
تماما معرضه لدمار
النظام الايراني ليست المره ليس المره
الاولى التي يقوم بها بقصف هذه الاماكن
يعرض المدنيين مصر الاندومي مئات الالاف
على اراضي الاقليم يتجمعون في معسكرات
خاصه تحت اشراف منظمات دوليه ورقابه دوليه
وليس لديهم اي نشاط امني او عسكري سوا
النشاطات السياسيه لكن النظام الايراني
في كردستاني ايران تحاول ان تمارس الضغوط
كي ينعكس الامر في الداخل همم شكرا لك يا
دكتور يعني انتهى الوقت كان بودي عنك شكرا
لك يا دكتور نبي استاذ الفلسفه السياسيه
في جامعه الكويت
نشرت قناه ايران انترناشونال تسريب صوتيه
لاحد قاده قوه البسيج يظهر هلا عن نظام
الايراني من الاحتجاجات التي عمت المدن
الايرانيه
[موسيقى]
العمر ما ينفعش اقعد
يوم
[موسيقى]
ين والصلاه على النبي
حماسيه جدا قبيلا انطلاق لقاء الولايات
المتحده وايران ساعود الى هناك مع الزميل
ليث بازار ليسا كيف اصبحت الصوره من هناك
وكيف كانت الدخول الى داخل الملعب
يعني الدخول كان صعب يا ليال بسبب بسيط
انه اليوم كما كنا قبل قليل في المباشر
انه يوجد حراسه كبيره وانه يوجد كيو ار او
مسح كود خاص لدخول المباراه وكل شخص يريد
ان يدخل يجب ان يتبع هذه الارقام والحراسه
الزائده هي التي تكون عاده بسبب طبعا
تنظيم مقاعد المشجعين يعني المقاعد على
يمين البوابه الرئيسيه هي الامريكيون
والمقاعد على اليمين الايسر للبوابه
الرئيسيه لل- همم للايرانيون ولذلك يعني
هنا كانت العقبه امامنا وسبب اخر ان
الكاميرا تعرفون كيف يمكن يعني حقوق نشر
الصور خصوصا دخول استاد يوم او الملعب هنا
همم في في مونديال قطر ولكن يعني اذا
شاهدنا في عمق الصوره نشاهد بعض الذين
حضروا فقط لمشاهده يعني يوجد شخص امريكي
سي
امريكا يوجد شخص امريكي يحاول الدخول حتى
يعني تشجيع منتخب بلده والكثير من الذين
حضروا نشاهد نرصد ذلك همم منذ بدايه
المونديال انهم ياتون الى هذه المنطقه على
امل ان يعني يستطيعون الدخول الى داخل
استاد ومشاهده او رصد همم لاعب همم
منتخبها او المنتخب الذي يشجعون يعني شفنا
كمان هناك الكثير من
الطائرات التي تحلق طائره مروحيتان تحلقان
في اجواء المنتخب وقبل قليل عندما دخل هذه
القصه الطريفه تركنا الترايبود او همم
علبه همم التي توضع فيها همم ستاد
الكاميرا تركناه في الخارج واذا برج
سكيورتي وهو رجل بريطاني طلب الرجال العام
قال لي بحرفيا المباراه بين ايران وامريكا
وانت تركت ال- هذه الصندوق هنا هذا خطر
جدا وطبعا بعد ذلك ما حضرت يعني تداركنا
الامر وانتهت الموضوع بسلام الحمد لله
ولكن اذا تكلمنا عن يعني اجواء همم
المونديال وخصوصا هذه المباراه بين ايران
والولايات المتحده شاهدت كثير يعني ما
لفتني شيء هو يوجد حفله موسيقيه لل جي جي
امريكي هنا واذا بالكثير من الايرانيون
يتها يعني يقبلون على سماع موسيقى والرقص
مع هذا الدي جي وهذا شيء جميل ان يجمع
يعني المونديال او مونديال قطر 2022 اشخاص
يجتمعون حول الموسيقى والرياضه
هناك طبعا شاهدنا برده رصدنا اثناء دخول
المشجعين الى الى الملعب الى الاستاذ
رصدنا ان هناك كانت طريقه بطريقه مرحه
طبعا من يقول امريكا ومن يقول ايران في
نفس الوقت فالهافات كانت تنتج همم عند
دخول الملعب وال منهم تبادل يعني باي
شاهدت السيده تحمل العلم الايراني وهي
امريكيه ورجل ايراني يحمل العلم الامريكي
وهم داخلون وهم يدخلون الى الى ستديو شكرا
لك ليس على هذه الرساله طبعا نعم يعني
سنكون معك طيله هذه الليله من متابعه كل
مجريات هذه المباراه شكرا لك لايت غزال
مشاهدينا فاصل قصير ونعود الى التاسع
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اكدت احدث التقارير
العسكريه التي نقلتها صحيفه لوفي الفرنسيه
ان كوريا الشماليه تعتمد اساليب غير
مشروعه لتمويل تصنيع واطلاق صواريخها
البلاستيكيه واخر الطرق القرصنه وسرقه
الملايين من العملات
[موسيقى]
صوري اخوكم النوويه وقودها رقمي مشفر فخف
هذه التجارب المكثفه تقف الاف القطع من
بيتكوين وشبيهاتها بيونجا التي تتفاخر
بامتلاكها حوالي 1000 صاروخ بالستيه لم
يسبق لها ان اطلقت هذا الكلمه من الصواريخ
كما العام الحالي اكثر من 75 صاروخا 23
منها اطلقتها في الثاني من نوفمبر الجاري
وحده
ورغم ان تكلفه تصنيع هذه الصواريخ
وتجريبها قد تكون اقل تكلفه في كوريا
الشماليه مما هي عليه في بلدان اخرى الا
ان صحيفه لوفيجارو الفرنسيه قدر التكلفه
الصواريخ التي اطلقت هذا الشهر بين 50 و
75 مليون دولار وهو مبلغ ضخم بالنسبه لبلد
معزوله ومستهدف بالعقبات لكن للزعيم
الشمالي وقراصنه رايا اخر عام 2014 قام
قراصنه كوريون شماليون يعرفون باسم
لازاروست باختراق بيانات شركه سوني
بيكتشرز اليابانيه ونفذ مئات اختراقات
الفديه حول العالم المجموعه نفسها كانت
وراء سرقه هائله للعملات المشفره بعد ان
اخترقت شبكه رونو للدفع الرقميه المستخدمه
في لعبه اكس انفينيتي وسرقه ما يعادل 615
مليون دولار من العملات المشفره الامر
تكرر عام 2019 شروه 2020 فوفقا لخبراء
الامم المتحده استطاع قراصنه بيونغيانغ
سرقه ما يفوق 315 مليون دولار من الاصول
الافتراضيه اما هذا العام فيقدر ما سرقه
القراصنه الكوريون الشماليون بملياردولار
من العملات المشفره هجمات الكترونيه تمنح
كوريا الشماليه طريقه رخيصه لكسب الكثير
من المال
تنضم الينا عبر الزور
الباحثه في مؤسسه الدفاع عن الديمقراطيه
همم يعني السرقه لتمويل برنامج الصواريخ
والبرنامج النووي طبعا لتخفيف الض- بعد
الضغوط الاقتصاديه والعقوبات لماذا هذه
البراعه بالسرقه وهل تكفي لتمويل هذا
البرنامج
شو عندك سمك شكرا
معروفه في عمليات انتهاك هجمات صبرانيه من
اجل تمويل برامجها النوويه وبرنامجها
الصاروخيه فضلا عن برامجها الخبيثه الاخرى
وهذا بات جزءا لا يتجزا من امدادات تمويل
النظام
القطيع التي يعيشها وهناك جمله من
العقوبات المتعدده الاطراف التي فرضت على
النظام ما حدى به لاستخدام الهجمات
الصبرنيه لتعويض العجز في الميزانيه
مبالغ كبيره تم فرقتها عبر السنوات
الماضيه منذ عقد من الزمن لماذا يعني ما
زالت هذه الاساليب همم يعني يستطيعون
استخدامه وبهذه الكسره
يا نور
المطلوب كما هو الحال بالنسبه لروسيا
والصين هذا ياتي جزءا من ان العمليات
كوريا الشماليه قد يكون لها طابعا اجرامي
في توجهاتها في ما يتعلق بجمع الاموال
امنيه لكنها مختلفه عن العمليات التي
نراها
من قبل روسيا والصين التي تهدد من خلالها
امن امريكا القومي وان كوريا الشماليه
تركزه وفي المقام الاول على تمويل لذلك
بالانتباه الامني المطلوب لكنها يجب ان
تذهب دون ان تلاحظ
زعيم كوريا الشماليه دائما ما يقول ان
هدفه سيلاك اكبر قوه نوويه وبالستيه حول
العالم اليوم بما ان يعني الاداره تعلم
مصادر التمويل وسط كل الضغوط الاقتصاديه
التي يعاني منها النظام لماذا لا يتم
الضغط على مصادر وتشفيف مصادر التمويل وهل
ممكن ان تكفي هذه العمليات لكي تصبح كوريا
من اعظم القوى النوويه
ان تقوم بحد قدرات كوريا الشماليه لجنه
عمليه عمليه
الاطلاق صواريخ نوويه وكذلك ايضا لمجابهه
الجمله من العمليات التي تقدم عليها هذا
روسيا والصين بدايه الطبع في هو ذلك في
نطاقا واسع من العمليات السبرانيه لكن
الفارقه يكمون بان الامر قد يكون اكثر
صعوبه في قطع التمويل
لان هذا قد يقوضه بقدرته كوريا الشماليه
في الانقراض في عمليات غسل اموال اخرى
وابتعادها عن النظام المالي العالمي اذ ان
هناك تاريخ كبير للعقوبات الماليه
والتواطؤ بين المصارف الخاصه في كوريا
الشماليه لكن هذا الامر قد يكون مختلفا في
العمله المشفره
المؤسسات قد لا تكون واضحه على الصعيدي
الانظمه الماليه التي تسعى بالابتعاد عن
مراقبه الولايات المتحده وغيرها من الدول
هناك الان همم تفاهم بشان الحاجه لحتى
عمليه غسل الاموال
ديمقراطيه تحدثنا
[موسيقى]
في سوريا اعلنت الامم المتحده عن وصول اول
دفعه من لقاحات الكوليرا الى دمشق وقالت
المنظمه في بيان لها ان شاحنات تحمل
مليونيه جرعه من لقاح الكوليرا الفموي
وصلت الى العاصمه السوريه دمشق للاستجابه
للانتشار المتسارع للوباء بعد الابلاغ عن
عشرات الالاف من الحالات وبحسب البيان فان
اللقاحات ستستخدم في حمله تحصين تبدا في
الرابع من ديسمبر المقبل تشمل الفئات
الاشد ضعفا ضمن المحافظات الاكثر تضارارا
وعلى راسها حلب والرقه والحسكه ودار
[موسيقى]
حرب مصغره او السباقيه عشانها له ماسك
مالك تويتر الجديده على شركه التكنولوجيا
العملاقه ابل ليفجر مفاجاه من العيار
الثقيل باعلانه ان الاخير قد توقف قد توقف
التطبيق من متجر ابل ستور فهل تستطيع ابل
القيام بذلك امر سهل للغايه وماسك نفسه
يعرف ذلك وهذا ما دفعه للتهديد بتصنيع
هاتف جديد ينافس ابل وجوجل اذا ما قاموا
بحذف تويتر من متاجر التطبيقات ابل فعلتها
سابقا فقط في يناير عام 2021 تطبيق الذي
كان يعتبر موطنا للمحافظين من الحزب
الجمهوري وماذا لانصار الرئيس الامريكي
السابق
وبرلت قرارها هذا الذي جاء ذلك قبل ايام
من اقتحام انصار ترامب مبنى الكابتل
الشهير في واشنطن بان التطبيق انتهك قواعد
وروج للعنف والكراهيه هذا يعني انا ابل
لديها الحق او يمكنها على الاقل حضرت وتر
لكن المساله ليست بهذه البساطه مع تطبيق
قوي وفعال مثل تويتر لان حضره قد يفتح
جدلا ونقاشا قانونيا واسعا ومحتدما في
الولايات المتحده وغيرها طبعا من البلدان
وقتي يدفع حتى الى الكونجرس للتدخل
نهايه التاسع
القطريه بالتعاون مع الفيفا بتكثيف اعداد
قوات الامن والحمايه الاجراءات الامنيه
مشدده داخل الملعب الثمامه وخارجه قبيله
لقاء المنتخبين الامريكي والايراني
[موسيقى]
الشتاء يجبر الناتو على التدخل في
اوكرانيا قطع غيار ومولدات لتعويض نقص
الطاقه
[موسيقى]
طهران تستغل اتفاقا امنيا بين اربيل
واحزاب ايران الكرديه يمنعها من الرد على
صواريخ الحرس الثوري
لبرنامجها الصاروخي عبر قرصنه ملايين
الدولارات الرقميه
مشاهدينا التاسعه انتهت لكن اخبار العربيه
مستمره كما كل ليله والان الى 360 مع
زملاء راويه وطاهر راويه وطهر ماذا لديكم
الليل اهلا بك ليال سنتحدث عن الغضب
العالم الحاصل الان في ايران بعد انتحار
ما يسمى بطفل العمامه
في الكونجرس الامريكي ترد على بايدون
وتقول له في موضوع اوكرانيا على الاقل لن
يوقع شكا على بياض